[Music]
hello everyone
bandit here the zelda franchise is full
of dualities
kind of like how i'm the good bandit and
he's the bad bandit
wait why am i the bad bandit
shut up bad bandit your entire existence
was as a joke and you now serve no
purpose to me
dude did you just throw a knife in my
chest
that kills people man man there's blood
everywhere this is
outrageous i can't believe you would
kill i'm basically you
this is so frustrating you've got link
and dark link the light realm and the
dark realm and even hyrule and low rule
the use of duality is present in most
areas of the franchise if you look close
enough but one of them that not too many
fans are keen on goes all the way back
to the first zelda game
did you know that the master sword has a
double or an opposite
if you will that i'm very surprised
actually that there aren't more theories
about you see the entire premise of the
game is also focused on this idea of
duality or parallelism
you've got hylia and the forces of the
light protecting the triforce and you've
got demise and the forces of darkness
trying to take it their introductions
are even stylized to resemble one
another in the opening
cutscene hylia created the goddess sword
with which to do battle against demise
and demise created his own version
let's just call it the demon sword to do
battle against hylia but the purpose of
this video isn't necessarily to answer
where the demon sword came from we kind
of just did that but in looking closer
at these two swords and their
similarities and differences
i think it'll reveal more to us about
their creators hylian demise and
potentially even some
other characters but real quick before
we start i just wanted to throw out
there that if you've been a fan of my
channel for long or maybe you've watched
a couple of my videos by this point you
may remember that i just did a video on
the whole
two master swords idea i just wanted to
specify that this video
is nothing like that video and if you've
seen that video then you know what i'm
talking about and if not i'll link it in
the description below it's also a really
good theory and speaking of viewing my
videos i wanted to also let you know
that about
80 of all of my viewers are actually not
subscribed to the channel so if you
enjoy my content on the channel i humbly
ask that you consider subscribing it
only takes a quick little
click and you can always unsubscribe if
i lose my touch at any point in the
future
but of course either way i sincerely
appreciate you being here right now
so where was i oh yes the demon sword i
briefly mentioned a little bit ago that
it was the goddess swords parallel
counterpart but i'm sure a lot of you
are thinking
what exactly is supposed to be parallel
about these two swords i'm so glad you
asked you see in the first place
both blades are created by a deity that
much we already know
both blades are also sentient highly
created fight not only to be a spirit
that lives within the blade to aid the
hero in his quest but to also
literally be the blade it's no accident
that her uh
clothing represents the style and
coloration of the master sword and also
it's revealed to us in breath of the
wild that she
literally speaks as the master sword and
also also even though hyrule warriors
isn't a canon zelda title
the first game features her as a
playable character and in that game as
part of her moveset
she literally transforms into the
goddess sword and this is further proven
by looking at
fee's counterpart the demon sword also
known as
girikin not only is his entire character
design
very familiar complete with a little
swirly hairdo but at the end of the game
the blade is heavily implied to
literally be him and moments later after
his and link's battle the blade is
pulled
from his body both of these blades also
function the exact same in that they are
both
skyward swords capable of skyward
strikes and
as if the creation and sentience and
powers of these two swords weren't
already enough to prove their
parallelism there's also the matter of
their design the master sword has a
pointed pommel a winged design guard
with three points
a gemstone and is a double-edged
broadsword which just means that the
sword was designed more for cutting
instead of
stabbing on the other hand the demon
sword has a pointed pommel
wing design guard with three points a
gemstone and is also a double-edged
broadsword even though its blade is
weirdly spiky
because as we all know spikes are a
clear sign of evil
there's also the matter of their symbol
that's on the blade the triforce
now both of the blades have the same
symbol but the inverted master swords is
inverted some people claim that this is
a reference to laurel since laurel's
version of the triforce
is also an inverted version and they
take that one step further and say that
that is proof for demise's origin
i see it as a different way more of a
branding way and you know what i'm going
to use to illustrate this point
utensils let's go to my kitchen and look
at a spoon for a second
go to the kitchen what's going on
what are you doing buddy hi hi buddy all
right again we talked about this right
you're not gonna go destroy any more
civilizations right
bring it there he goes he's gonna go
destroy them okay the kitchen
as you can see when you're looking at a
spoon this isn't a spoon
oh man sometimes i worry about myself
anyway when you're looking at a spoon
a lot of the times there's something
engraved in it and this engraving is
normally more like a branding thing
applying this logic to the twin blades
we know that neither hylia nor demise
created the triforce
yet the triforce is the center point of
both of their existences
hylia branded her blade with the symbol
of what she's trying to protect and
demise branded his blade with the symbol
of what he's trying to obtain
he just inverted it because he's
anti-it's protector
anti-hylia long story short both blades
are essentially
exactly parallel to each other but this
is the point where the video is going to
kind of pivot and we start getting into
some really fun speculations so
fasten your seat belts since the two
blades are essentially parallel to one
another
just inverted what about the ones who
gave them their purpose
their creators i mean let's think about
it for a second both highly end demise
are deities one being a goddess and the
other being
the king of demons both have similar
powers and can create
sentient spirit weapons both are
responsible for the events of the entire
franchise with
highly creating and becoming zelda and
demise creating the curse
and neither of them are members of the
original golden goddess trio that
created the universe and the triforce
but yet
both of them are directly related to the
triforce and speaking of demise
like i just mentioned he's known as a
demon king right what exactly is a demon
in the zelda franchise anyway i mean on
the flip side we call hylia a goddess
but that's kind of confusing because
she's not
one of the morally neutral golden
goddesses that created the universe
she like demise is clearly a different
kind of being
lower exists on the earth and is even
documented to be able to suffer from
wounds like she did in the ancient
battle against demise all things
considered
she sounds less like one of the original
golden goddesses and more like what
christian teachings say an angel would
be which would be a being that was
created by god or in this case the
goddesses that is
lower than the goddesses but made to
serve them but an angel is also higher
in status than humanity and is also
immortal and they're known to engage in
warfare
and by these same christian teachings
which no joke the entire zelda franchise
was actually based off of and you should
totally look that up when you have the
chance
you know what a demon is a fallen angel
so what if demise and hylia the demon
and the goddess
were at one point both the same kind of
being and to expound on this idea albeit
in a slightly
different way in the very same game
skyward sword that introduced us to the
demon
king we were also introduced to a
friendly demon this guy whose name is
batro i believe is how you pronounce it
who get this
if you complete his optional quest line
actually turns from a demon
into a human meaning that the status of
being a demon
can be altered it's canon it's in the
game
so what if the inverse is also true
what if a demon can become a demon
having been something else originally
according to batro he was cured by
gratitude crystals which are essentially
the
literal embodiments of good vibes in the
game what if demise was transformed into
a demon
by the inverse by the evil crystals that
are the literal
embodiments of malicious intent evil
crystals can curse
gratitude crystals can cure evil and
gratitude light and dark
phy and giroheim god a sword and demon
sword and hylia
and demise see the duality is present
everywhere
and i also believe that it applies to
the two individuals who started it all
also and this is the last thing i'll
throw out there before i wrap this video
up since we know that link is hylia's
chosen hero who ultimately she created
the goddess sword for
what if the inverse also known as dark
link
is demise's chosen since he is the
inverse of the spirit of the hero and
his coloration looks a lot
like the demon sword but that is just
super speculation at this point i just
thought it was neat to think about this
concept of parallelism in the zelda
games and speaking of thinking
what did you guys think of this theory
are hylian demise really parallel
counterparts to each other which
explains all these weird coincidences in
the game
or is it all just that coincidences let
me know in the comments below also thank
you so much for watching
if you enjoyed the video and you're
still watching at this point please
consider leaving a like below so that
this video gets spread around
to all sorts of zelda fans just like you
and me huge thanks as always to my
bandit crew
especially the ruffian trickster and
masked bandit members if you're
interested in joining up with my elite
crewmates and reaping some pretty epic
benefits along the way and not to
mention helping the next video come to
life
please consider checking out that join
button located below or the links in my
description to my patreon page
also down there you will find the links
to my social media pages so come follow
me on
twitter and instagram for some spicy
bandit-isms that was probably the
weirdest way i could have said that but
we're gonna go with it anyway that is
all i've got for this one as always i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day
this is mason town abandoned signing out
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you